nos gueules maintenant s'être agi
matches suivants pénible tenait la face
tout à plat tout était moche non merci
ça me touche beaucoup
qu'est ce qu'on va faire de maman on n'a
qu'à la butte est tout simplement je
savais que toi tu as vu du bon sens tu
es complètement malade
oui c'est n'importe quoi si tu faisais
plus amour tu ne grossira pas autant
elle seule chose que tu as passé saint
malo fait la dictée la vioque merci la
danse nul la musique culte une lente ou
mieux q p des onze conne
ok c'est bon elle a buté mais ça dans
son mojito et zou pas un bon premier
meurtre auprès pas réservé reese
t'inquiète pas on t'a préparé un truc
costaud
[Musique]
am impressionnera toujours